so here are some photos of celebrities
and queer relationships that you might
not have known about or ever seen Lily
Rose Depp and 070 Shake are a couple
they keep things kind of DL but
sometimes we post them together on her
story this is nisi Nash and Jessica
Betts so this is cow pen and his fiance
Josh I had never seen a photo of like
RuPaul's husband but this is him his
name is George labar this is Kristen
Stewart and Dylan Meyer Jim Parsons and
Todd spewack Billy Porter and Adam Smith
the hilarious Ross Matthews and
willafriend Garcia this is Matt Bomer
and Simon Halls and this is Jesse Tyler
Ferguson and Justin Makita